aquí Hace unos días había un edificio de
12 plantas uno de los más antiguos de
este barrio según nos explican los
propios vecinos y de aquí fueron
rescatadas algunas personas con vida sin
embargo la mayoría de los habitantes de
este edificio parecieron ahora las
tareas de rescate ya han terminado y los
vecinos del lugar han levantado un
pequeño mausoleo encima de unas de unos
restos de hormigón con antiguos objetos
de los que antes habitaban aquí son
libretas para aprender inglés libros de
texto de ciencias de la información
algunas fotos familiares libros y
también algunos peluches ahora mismo las
tareas de rescate siguen en algunas
partes pero sobre todo las grandes
tareas ahora mismo es intentar recuperar
los cadáveres de los que ya para
probablemente estén muertos dentro de
los escombros y sobre todo saber si los
edificios que han quedado en pie son
habitables o no ahora mismo mientras
Veníamos a este lugar hemos visto varios
equipos del gobierno Turco entrar en los
edificios al lado de este para poder
dirimir si son habitables si no daños
estructurales o no uno de los edificios
de aquí al lado una vecina nos decía que
su edificio sí que será habitable según
nos contaba ella misma Pese que tiene
daños estructurales o desde fuera parece
que los tiene el edificio hay detrás
según nos comentaba sí que será de ruido
en los próximos días